Speaker 1: All right.
Let's hear from some of you through the Friday
feedback segment where emails, Facebook comments,
YouTube comments, smoke signals, telegrams,
Twitter replies, all sorts of communications
with the show may be featured on Fridays.
If you just want to keep it simple and send
an email, you can email info at David Pakman
dot com.
I have to admit this first message I don't
understand if this is from a Nazi or from
someone warning me about Nazis and saying
they have taken over.
The message is as follows The weak fear.
The swastika.
You all had your chances to deal with this.
You dropped the ball.
We told you for years we are everywhere.
And eventually we would have to come out.
Well, here we are.
Now it's our time to deal with these Weimar
conditions.
Welcome to National Socialism.
Is this a Nazi saying we have now taken over
because you didn't stop us?
Or is this an anti-Nazi saying because you
didn't stop them?
The Nazis are now here.
I genuinely have no idea.
Someone else knows what that message is about.
Please let me know.
The anti-trans movement continues and it continues
plaguing our YouTube channel.
User des Ro QC says Thank God for people like
Michael Knowles and Matt Walsh.
These are anti-trans guys from The Daily Wire
fighting against the groomers who are aiming
their filth at our children.
We are way past being polite and tolerant
with you bunch of degenerates trying to indoctrinate,
confuse and mutilate kids.
I don't know.
What this person is talking about.
And as I've said before, it seems as though
no one is aiming anything at children.
But we do have things that exist which parents
can decide, I will bring my kid to that or
I won't bring my kid to that.
And that that's the freedom I thought the
right wing advocated for.
I thought that's exactly what they wanted.
It's very confusing.
Rated R judge has a different view about the
anti-trans hysteria and says, Let's find a
small, marginalized group of harmless people
and really stomp on them and make their lives
miserable.
Just to show how big and strong and brave
we are.
You know, this reminded me it's a very good
point.
This reminded me of Arnold Schwarzenegger's
recent video, 12 minute video, which was.
It dealt with discrimination of all kinds.
And certainly you could tell that he was pushing
back against the anti-trans rhetoric, but
it was also pushing back against anti-Semitism.
And one of the great points that Arnold made,
referring to his own father, who was a Nazi
sympathizer, was all of these movements, these
groups, these coalitions based on hate, they
end up being losers at the end of the day.
You never look back at them and say, those
were the winners, the people who opposed women
voting.
We don't.
Those were the losers.
They they hindered obvious progress in the
United States, the Nazis in World War Two,
of course, the anti-gay people who for 20
years shouted about to if you let two men
marry, next thing you know, people will be
allowed to marry horses.
They're losers.
They are.
And when you look at this comment, which is
it's not a very big thing, big and big.
I mean, Alpha, right, to choose the weakest
people and to say that's who we're going to
go after.
Excellent comment.
And I couldn't couldn't agree more.
Here's a comment about critical race theory.
This individual.
Why am I?
Mr. Pink says the issue with critical race
theory is that it teaches the idea that systemic
racism is a thing when it is not.
No one on the right wants to stop the teaching
of history.
They hate the lies about it.
Also, history is complex.
Take the issue of slavery.
After slavery was banned, many still worked
for their owners.
Why?
Why didn't they pursue a new career and become
landowners?
Because many were fine in the position they
were in.
That last part is pretty crazy.
The reason some slaves continued working for
their owners when they were technically freed
was that there was still all sorts of between
the lines.
Discrimination that was allowed in was happening,
and because many of those folks in their individual
situations didn't really have much of a choice
with what money were they going to go and
buy land.
It doesn't make any sense.
But let's go to the to the more important
part.
It teaches the idea that systemic racism is
a thing when it is not.
Listen, there have been major advances in
the United States when it comes to dealing
with systemic racism of different kinds.
And that has taken place to different degrees.
We still have a number of different systemic
realities in the United States that go above
and beyond the individual.
For example, there are still significant effects
when it comes to public transit.
In many cities where the historically redlined
neighborhoods disproportionately represented
by minorities are much less well connected
via public transit.
That's a systemic issue.
That's a systemic issue where in certain neighborhoods
you're going to have more of an issue getting
to jobs in certain parts of the city.
And the reason that that is the case is because
it is a vestige of racial racist redlining.
That's a systemic issue.
That doesn't mean every aspect of society
is racist.
There have been a number of interesting studies
done where the same resumes are submitted
with traditionally identifiably white sounding
names and black sounding names.
No difference whatsoever when it comes to
the credentials and the white sounding names
are much more likely to get an initial interview.
That's a systemic issue.
You could be.
The idea is you're just as qualified.
But because of a name that is stigmatized
with a particular race, you're less likely
to even get the opportunity to prove yourself
in an interview.
That's a systemic issue.
Now, that doesn't mean that there haven't
been great improvements made as well.
So the idea that there are no systemically
racist issues doesn't make much sense.
Gerald says.
I wish every Republican doing an interview
would be asked to explain what critical race
theory is and explain what work is.
Yeah, me too.
We've talked about this before.
When they're asked to explain critical race
theory, they usually spit out.
It teaches white kids that they are bad because
they're white.
Hmm.
I missed that day in class.
And when you ask them about woke, I mean,
last week, even Fox host Dana Perino said
woke can just be a feeling or a sense.
Here is another question relating the drag
show stuff to, I guess, irresponsible parenting.
This user's user says, Would you, David, hand
the car keys to your child and say, go have
fun, go as fast as you want.
This is equal to taking your child to a drag
show that escalated pretty quickly.
No, I mean, listen, in six years I will start
teaching my daughter how to drive and I will
teach her the rules of the road and I will
teach her about road safety.
And she will have to go to driver's ed and
complete a number of hours of driver training
and all of that.
And then I will still continue to espouse
the need to be careful when driving.
And I can't think of any way.
In which that relates at all to a drag show.
I just I'm really racking my brain and I'm
not understanding how there's a connection
between learning to drive safely.
And taking a kid to a drag show.
Maybe someone can explain it to me.
Giddy one posted to the subreddit about me
saying no president has ever been arrested,
that it is false.
And I received a few of these messages.
This particular post says President Ulysses
S Grant.
Or if I were Trump, I would pronounce it Ulysses.
But Ulysses S Grant was arrested in 1872 for
dangerous driving.
He was fined and did not contest the arrest
or fine.
Then going on to say President Franklin Pierce
was arrested for running over a pedestrian
while driving his carriage in Washington,
possibly drunk driving.
He was arrested but released when his identity
became known.
So two things about this.
It is absolutely the case that I misspoke
and I wanted to say indicted, which I think
would have made my comment more accurate.
But my research suggests that the Franklin
Pierce story is questioned.
What I read conflicting accounts, and some
say that it is not a true story about Franklin
Pierce, but I'm not sure.
But in any case, it does appear that Trump
wouldn't be the first president arrested.
But I believe from my research it is accurate
to say indicted.
But we are going to continue looking into
it very, very strongly.
Another post from the subreddit asks, and
this this hit home, folks, Is social media
just not worth it?
It's so goddamned infuriating logging on and
seeing the most smugly braindead, easily debunked
B.S.
get thousands of likes and shares.
I gave up arguing with them long ago because
exactly zero of them will change their minds
as a result.
And I'll just get agitated with the stupidity
while they fly back to the flock to claim
victory.
I know ignoring these clowns won't make them
go away.
But man, is it frustrating.
I have said for a long time.
I don't engage in social media arguments.
Now, it's easy for me to say because I have
a platform where I can do much more in an
hour than in 10 hours arguing with individuals
on Twitter.
I understand not everybody has that, but my
advice continues to be, I don't know that
I would either get involved with it.
For me, social media is I want to see what
is being said, but it's not for then starting
to type furiously at people.
That's I believe it is an exercise in frustration
and I sympathize with that completely.
We try on our platforms, like the very subreddit
that this this message is from.
We try to make it a more positive and controlled
environment.
We don't allow, you know, direct harassment.
And of course, people can disagree.
We don't allow slurs and these sorts of things.
But at the end of the day, sometimes it's
just while your opinions really aren't based
in fact, and there's really nothing I can
do about that, and that is certainly a sad
thing.
But I would agree with this person.
This view ignoring won't make them go away,
but arguing with them on Twitter won't make
them change their minds.
And so we have to work in a different way.
We have to work through campaigns.
We have to work through activism.
And that is much more effective than, you
know, arguing with someone on TikTok or whatever
the case may be.
Get your messages in info at David Pakman
Dotcom, or through any of the other means
that you can get in touch with us.
We will have such a great bonus show for you
today.
And if you don't have access to the bonus
show because you're not a member, then we
will be back on Monday with a new podcast
for you.